carlos leitao et le porte parole de
l'opposition officielle en matière
d'économie et de lutte aux changements
climatiques ancien ministre des finances
bonsoir monsieur l'état au bon soin
figure à tahoua quand même pas mal aidé
les entreprises avaient depuis le début
de la crise et québec aussi on a eu des
prêts de plus de 50 mille de moins de 50
milles
pourquoi aujourd'hui ça prend un plan de
sauvetage spécifique pour les pme selon
vous vous pour deux raisons la première
vous l'avez mentionné les gouvernements
ont utilisé jusqu'à maintenant surtout
des prêts pour aider les pme est dans
une situation de crise où nous sommes
ces entreprises là les pme surtout les
plus petites ont d'énormes défis de
liquidités ça fait deux trois mois
qu'ils ont eu zéro revenus donc de la
dette je pense pas que ce soit ce dont
elles ont besoin
et deuxièmement c'est ce qui est
particulièrement important c'est que
cette récession parce que c'est de ça
qu'il s'agit de nous nous vivons une
récession vraiment presque sens en
parallèle cette question a frappé les
pme du québec comme du canada de façon
très dur et très particulier à ce n'est
pas comme une récession traditionnels
c'est vraiment les pme sont extrêmement
touchée par cette récession et il nous
faut un brin d'urgence nous sommes
encore dans l'urgence les syndicats
quand vous avez dit il propose des
mesures de relance vous avez scooter
quand les syndicats disent
réindustrialiser le québec où un québec
bas et actes là vous en pensez quoi de
ça bon on en discutera nous sommes
toujours dans l'urgence je pense qu'il
faut sauver ccp eve parce que sinon un
grand nombre d'entre elles vont faire
faillite n'est pas quand je prenais pas
encore dans la relance non justement on
est encore je sais qu'il fait beau
dehors il fait chaud on commence à des
confiné tout le monde est un peu plus
optimiste mais malheureusement nous
sommes encore d'une récession très
profonde et encore un sentiment
d'urgence
ce particulièrement pour les pm puisque
la relance on en reparlera
les suggestions des syndicats il ya des
choses intéressantes
le bike actes
ça je trouve que ça se tirer dans le
pied pourquoi bon parce que là on va
rejoindre les les instants
protectionnistes comment on pourrait
répondre ou comme on peut répondre aux
prétentions par exemple du gouvernement
américain de mettre encore d'autres
clauses de buy america si nous on fait
la même chose ici donc je pense que
c'est délicat
voilà la question de commerce
international notamment avec nous mais
on attendait depuis le début de la crise
le seul état où on a quand même beaucoup
parler d'achat local dans crucial où
elle a créé le calme et la production
locale qui est ce un peu plus souverain
sur le plan économique
tout à fait et je pense qu'on doit
utiliser des mesures de qui vont pour
mouvoir cela donc des incitatifs à la
production locale à l'achat local mais
de s'embarquer dans des mesures
restrictives qui garderait les produits
étrangers à l'étranger je pense qu'on
fait prudent là dessus
ok 12 à 15 milliards de dollars de
déficit
retour à l'équilibré dans trois à cinq a
fait plusieurs semaines que monsieur
girard dit cela est ce que ça tient la
route pour vous oui et non c'est une
bonne réponse écrevisses oui et donc je
pense que 12 à 15 milliards c'est
probablement ça qui va être rendu public
demain
maintenant je dirais pour ce qui est du
retour à l'équilibré terre que monsieur
zira va un peu trop vite dans le sens où
c'est beaucoup trop tôt à ce moment ci
de dire déjà que on va revenir à
l'équilibré à 3 5
on sait pas encore quand est ce que
cette récession
quand je vois qu'on va atteindre le
creux de cette récession le sort encore
dans l'urgence en très grand nombre
d'entreprises risquent de faire faillite
la relance risque d'être beaucoup plus
laborieuse que ce qu'on pense donc le
retour avec les budgétaires on en
discutera en temps et lieu c'est un peu
trop tôt pour s'engager déjà dans cette
dans cette direction quand vous êtes
arrivé au pouvoir en 2014
vous avez mené une politique que vous
qualifiez de rigueur certains ont ramené
sa de l'austérité pour revenir à
l'équilibré budgétaire
esquire et de girard doit faire la même
chose que vous
nous ce qu'on avait fait c'était ce qui
était approprié à ce moment là ça
faisait déjà aussi rappelé aux cinq ans
que la récession était terminée
donc c'est important de revenir à
l'équilibré c'est tout autre contexte
comme vous venez de mentionner pouvoir
construire dans un déficit de 12 à 15
milliards c'est énorme
donc il faut être prudent dans le chemin
qu'on va emprunter pour qu'il y est il
faut dire aussi c'est pas rien 12 à 15
milliards
revenir de 12 15 milliards quand vous
êtes arrivé puis on chip atropos d'euros
sur les chiffres mais on partait d'un
déficit de 2 3 milliards dont la lavande
versements au fonds des générations qui
vous est arrivé assez rapidement à des
milliards de surplus la revenir de 12 à
15 milliards ce sera beaucoup plus
complexe est tout à fait c'est pour ça
que je dis que c'est un peu trop tôt
trop prématuré de d'ores et déjà
s'engager à revenir dans une période de
3 à 5
il va falloir d'abord bien voir quels
sont les vrais dégâts de cette récession
et est ce que les 12 à 15 milliards est
ce que c'est purement conjoncturelle ou
est-ce qu'on s'engage dans une situation
où déficit structurel
donc avant de prendre de telles
décisions sur le le 300k étudions
d'abord la situation et vous ce serait
quoi
plus que cinq ans pour revenir l
équilibre
ça pourrait l'être ça pourrait l'être
tout dépendra de du dommage qui a été
fait à l'économie parce que la façon
dont on va s'en sortir c'est pas c'est
pas tellement compliqué c'est vraiment
la croissance économique le québec comme
le canada on finira par sortir
endettement qui ne fait qu'augmenter par
la croissance si la croissance
économique va être lente pendant
longtemps
ben à ce moment là ça va être beaucoup
plus difficile de sortir de la situation
des déficits si la croissance reprend
rapidement ça sera plus facile dans la
croissance ne reprendra pas rapidement
dès demain face à mettre en place des
mesures ou des animaux est ce qu'on doit
suspendre les versements au fonds des
générations
bonne question moi je vous dirais de
façon spontanée que non le fonds des
générations a toujours son utilité
surtout nous nous engageons maintenant
dans une situation probablement les
dépenses en santé vont augmenter de
façon structurelle et façon importante
donc le fond de génération a toujours
son utilité notamment en ce qui concerne
les besoins dé financement en santé à
l'avenir
merci d'avoir été avec nous monsieur
l'état aux bonnes soirées merci à vous
et bonne soirée